a factory in the belgian countryside
south of brussels but at the very heart
of an international diplomatic row
this is one of the places where
astrazeneca's covid19 vaccine is made
today the police were dropping by
yesterday it was health officials
they came here to check if this facility
really is suffering
from production problems they left with
samples and notes
and are reportedly due to return shortly
it is part of an increasingly
acrimonious standoff
astrazeneca says it can't supply europe
with the vaccines it orders
the european union says that is
unacceptable
obviously it is clearly for the company
to make proposals
to us on how it intends to fulfill
its terms of the of the contract and
therefore
we will be listening to the proposals
that come from
um that come from astrazeneca
the eu is about to bring in new laws
requiring more information when vaccines
are exported
it's also demanding astrazeneca but its
contract in the public domain
this factory is producing vaccines that
are supposed to save lives and
improve our world but the fact that it
was visited by
belgian officials dubious over
astrazeneca's excuses for production
delays
tells you everything about the profound
breakdown in trust between the company
and the european union the eu's argument
is that vaccines made in the uk should
be used to make up
europe's shortfall the president of the
european council was scathing in a
letter
he wrote so far the explanations
provided by some
pharmaceutical companies have not
provided us with the reassurances we
need
while continuing dialogue i believe the
eu needs to take
robust action to secure its supply of
vaccines
and demonstrate concretely that the
protection of its citizens
remains our absolute priority
but from others an effort to try to calm
this row
we don't doubt that the manufacturers
and the producers
are also working 24 7 to bridge the gap
and that i would remain confident that a
delay which we're seeing now is going to
made up
by extra production in the near future
europe's medical regulator is about to
decide
whether to authorize the astrozenica
vaccine come what may
germany will not offer it to those age
65 and above but make no mistake
whichever arms it goes in wherever they
are europe is
desperate for this vaccine and the heat
of this row shows
little sign of cooling adam parsons sky
news
sir belgium